[Music]
vr is already cool but to make it truly
immersive you don't just need your head
in another world you need your hands
there - these are the oculus touch the
company's brand new VR input devices and
they make something called hand presence
possible in VR but getting to this
design was a process of more than two
years of smart thinking and scores of
prototypes the very first thing that you
need in order to bring your hands into
VR is to have a perfectly tracked
solution much like a headset has
embedded LEDs that a sensor reads and
position something in space track
something in space they knew that the
hand controller needed to do the same
thing the very early investigations
hinged on how much space do we provide
to embed some infrared LEDs and let the
computer read these this is what it
would look like if we made it as easy as
possible for the computer but no one
wants to hold two school bus sized
steering wheels in their hands in order
to do something and as that tracking
portion Shrunk the question of how it
fit in your hand became something to
explore with something fit onto your
hand was it something that you could
hold almost like a flight stick the main
binary became is this something you're
gonna hold or is this something you're
going to wear when you wear something
has the obvious benefit of being able to
just open your hand and it's there but
getting these on and off left a lot to
be desired from a user experience
perspective now while that debate was
being had the decision of what to put on
this area on the face was going on what
are they gonna put here is it gonna be
thumb sticks is gonna be a d-pad like on
a regular game controller here's an
example of one thing that they tried for
the face of the controller it has an
analog thumb stick much like one you'd
see on a conventional game controller
but the more thinking that they did
about this the more they realized it
wasn't gonna work and why is that it's
cuz your thumb swings out a lot more
easily than it swings in so if you have
a centered thumb stick and you have
buttons on either side that's not going
to be comfortable over long stretches of
time so all this exploration really led
to this the culmination of a lot of
those decisions and once they got to
this the real design work
could begin it has a small ring with all
the embedded tracking on it it has a
trigger here and would eventually get
one here but on the face what you can
see is going on is that thumb stick is
more to the inside and the buttons are
to the outside
so from this came what's known as the
Halfmoon prototype this is something
that was brought to the e3 video game
show summer of 2015 and this was really
the first time that anybody outside of
oculus saw this device the tracking is
naked to the world you can see where
those LEDs are and you can see how the
thumbstick is beginning to take shape
you can see that secondary trigger is
here from here until now came some
iteration inside the company and it
eventually got us to the finished
product now what's going on here is more
than just having tracking that you can't
see hidden inside this ring of infrared
translucent plastic and is more than
having the finished triggers and the
finished input buttons and these thumb
sticks these buttons this thumb rest and
these thumb sticks all register when
your thumb is on them the triggers
register when you're pressing them so
through various permutations of having
your thumb on something resting away
from it let your hands and virtuality
give thumbs up grip things and that's
the kind of thing that actually gives
hand present it's not just our my hands
open or on my hands closed it's giving
our hands a set of discrete actions that
helps you translate the thing you're
trying to communicate into a vr
surrounding and so you're talking about
two and a half years of Design Thinking
and it all culminates in this the oculus
touch
you